and minimalists hello everybody welcome
to the minimalist podcast where we
discuss what it means to live a
meaningful life with less
my name is Joshua Fields Milburn and I'm
Ryan Nicodemus and together we are the
minimalists Mayor P this is episode 200
for us oh wow congratulations yeah thank
you for being here
we want to set politics aside today
because ours isn't really a political
podcast we wanted to talk to you about
values about contribution about
leadership about your minimalist uniform
we got a lot to talk about today so
we're gonna dive into it what we're here
with mayor Pete Buda judge he is a 2020
candidate for for president
it's quite the quite the leap from from
mayor and we're gonna talk about how we
can we can talk about transitioning from
from executive experience as mayor into
well potentially becoming president I
want to start off by saying Ryan and I
we have radically different political
beliefs spiritual beliefs that's what
makes this podcast so great so we're not
here to endorse a particular candidate
but I really like what Pete has put
together with his book with his message
and I thought a lot of things you talked
about they've really aligned with what
we talked about and I thought maybe it
would make sense to start by talking
about what does it mean to live a
meaningful life so for me I think it has
to do with making yourself useful I
think you just have a richer sense of
being alive if you know that it matters
in somebody else's day that you're there
or that it's you not somebody else doing
the particulars that you're doing and
that can take a lot of different forms
but for me obviously it's it's mainly
taken the form of service public service
and military service and the opportunity
to do that in the context of something
that you care about
I think certainly fills me with meaning
it's got some hazards to it let's talk
about some those hazards well one of the
hazards in politics is that when you're
in office you have a very meaningful job
I mean you can't miss the fact that what
you do matters because people are coming
up to you
all the time with often the most
important thing going on in their lives
and asking you to help
the problem with it's very fulfilling
thing the problem with it is it means
that because your work is meaningful
there is a risk that you will rely on
your work in order to make your life
meaningful and if you don't have meaning
without your job that means you need
your job a lot and part of being good in
public office is knowing that that there
are some things that are worth more than
your job that's part of what makes you
good at it is if there are some things
that you would be willing to lose your
job over do you know doing the right
thing yeah and so I've seen the the the
risk or the hazard of becoming dependent
literally for meaning on having a
certain title or a certain office and
and yet who can pass up the the chance
to do that kind of meaningful work
whenever you're whenever you're invited
to do it or feel like you have a chance
to do it how do you reconcile that then
because having meaningful work isn't
necessarily the same thing as having a
meaningful life I think you can derive a
significant amount of meaning from from
what you're doing but then there's of
course your values and your life outside
of work and I thought it'd be
appropriate to sort of talk about some
of those values you on your on your
website you put together a list of of
your values you call it the rules of the
road yeah and I thought maybe we could
talk about a few of those which one
which which of which of these stand out
to you I mean obviously they're all
important to you but Ryan and I are
often talking about our values core
values foundational values let's talk
about some of your values sure so we
have a set yeah we call them the rules
of the road because I want to make sure
anybody's part of this campaign whether
it's a volunteer or a supporter or a
staff member or myself that I'm held to
this to that we're working in a way
that's consistent and the very first one
on the list is respect because it's
really important especially given the
kind of environment as we all know that
surrounds politics and the coverage of
politics that we show a certain level of
respect for the office for each other
for the people that we're seeking to
serve for our competitors even and it
helps us model what I'm trying to do as
president before the first vote is ever
can
another very important value for us is
belonging so I think we actually have a
an emergency a crisis of belonging in
this country and I think our current
political environment is making it worse
and what we need to do right now is
build up a greater sense of belonging
knowing that this is also something that
feeds directly into health that you know
I think the reason we're seeing a lot of
what are called deaths from despair now
lives lost - to drugs to alcohol to
suicide often have to do with people
self-medicating for issues that are
connected to that that struggle for
belonging that that so many people feel
and so the other side of the coin is we
have a shot at in this campaign of
building out a sense of belonging just
by letting people know that they fit
into our vision for the country and
trying to reflect that in even our
events when we're out doing things we
think a lot about responsibility and
just the idea of the responsibility that
obviously goes with public office but
therefore that all of us involved in a
project to win public office in a
campaign ought to embrace and and owning
what we're working on I was really
heartened by by your ownership and one
of the debates when you said I didn't
get it done and and yeah I could tell it
was heartfelt but I could also tell like
you were willing to take radical
ownership of something because guess
what they're all all of us can recognize
that we don't get stuff done sometimes
even though we've tried we can't
accomplish everything that we try and I
think you know failure is obviously is
obviously a part of it and so taking
responsibility to me from someone who is
is a politician who is in public service
as opposed to just passing the buck
that's I think that's something that
that is significant and unfortunately
not something we see enough of well I
think it's definitely the instinct of a
mayor because you're you're on the
ground you're in this world where there
there's a lot of accountability for for
what has gone well and what hasn't you
don't come in promising that everything
will be fixed and and and so when
something doesn't get all go the
distance I need to acknowledge that
because we all as a city need to think
about no
what we would do differently but there's
no you know there's no alternative facts
when you're a mayor people can see
whether something went well something is
simple as snow plowing or something as
as deep and intractable as neighborhood
equality and and economic development so
you got owned it things go well you get
the credit things go poorly you got to
own up to what happened what you
could've done better yeah that's one
thing I'm really appreciate appreciate
about you is that you do and take
ownership but I think it's too often we
look for like this perfect candidate we
look for this you know perfect person to
be present and none of us are perfect so
it's like for me I don't want a I don't
want a perfect president I just want
someone who can take ownership and who
can be self-reflective and learned and
move forward speaking of learning your
book which by the way I have this theory
that all political memoirs are vapid
trite and empty and you totally
shattered that I think from you you
write gorgeously so so Bravo for that
and I think you've you put together a
book that was in many ways it was
written the prose was written like a
novel I felt like a lot of the time it
opened up with rage is a gorgeous scene
of South Bend some of the narrative sort
of overlay of the the scene where you're
running through South Bend is sort of
describing the city I thought that was a
now that was a beautiful narrative
device to sort of move things there and
give people who've never been to the
Midwest or to South Bend a sort of tour
of the city that the good and bad side
of things you talked a moment ago about
a crisis of belonging also a crisis of
meaning and Ryan and I from Dayton Ohio
a few years ago was the overdose capital
of America
a lot a lot going on there because a lot
of you're familiar with this was South
Bend a lot of the jobs left with the
manufacturing and that closed a whole
bunch of plants and people found
tremendous meaning in their work but
then they also fell and I think
especially today we did we feel like we
don't belong as much I saw a I saw a
survey of Millennials that they said I
think it was 23% of Millennials don't
even have an acquaintance
and if you think if you if you're
thinking about belonging you don't even
have an acquaintance you're so far from
a sense of community but it seems to me
that you've identified a you've been
able to establish or help reestablish a
sense of community can we talk about
some of the lessons that you've learned
being the mayor of South Bend some of
the ones you wrote about in your book
yeah part part of what I share in the
book why why it's called shortest away
home is that there's a saying the
longest way around is the shortest way
home and and it took me a while to
figure out how much belonging and
meaning was gonna come from my community
the place that I've grown up in the
place I couldn't wait to get out of when
I was 18 I think a lot of people who
grow up especially in smaller
communities or in the industrial Midwest
kind of take on board that message that
success means getting out yeah and why
is that you know I think but part of
it's because the trajectory has been so
tough in these cities and and part of it
is I think the allure of the the global
of the big city and I love big cities a
lot I love all of the world but there
was something that I didn't know I
needed waiting at home and part of it
had to do with that idea I shared
earlier about making herself useful the
fact that I could I could meaningfully
do things in my community that would
really have an impact on a lot of people
and that I had something to offer both
because I was from the community and
because I was in a kind of tension with
it you know you if you're exactly like
all of the people you serve then we
probably don't have that much to offer
them you're just a mirror right but if
if you have a little bit of tension I
grew up not sure I belonged in and and
had questions and problems with with my
city even as I began to realize once I
left that I also loved the place and so
realizing what was kind of waiting for
me all along is I think the story of
that part of my life and it's also the
story of the book I learned a lot of
lessons about just what it means to see
through the eyes of others a big part of
what happens when you're a mayor is you
you kind of channel all of the the hopes
and the fears and the frustrations of
others and then he got away that against
your own self your own understand
of what matters in the world and when
people who are radically different from
you
who might live a mile or two away from
you are in your face and you know this
isn't working for my neighborhood or
your you know the city's not taking care
of me or I want this to be different it
puts a big pressure on you it tears you
up a little bit actually but but then it
also helps you grow because you extend
yourself to all these these other people
and you you see a lot of a lot of cities
have found a different future Dayton's a
an example of a city actually with a
great mayor
in fact we've voted her in to be the
president or she's a vice president now
to eventually become the president of
the Conference of Mayors because so many
other mayor's are interested in what's
going on there I think precisely because
of the challenge I think if cities like
ours were prosperous homogeneous growing
cities with no real problems would be
kind of boring I don't think there'd be
much purpose yeah for somebody means
like me at least in in in serving but
because we know the magnitude of the
challenge in front of a city like mine
that was characterized as dying in the
media the same month that I got in the
race for mayor and is now you know by no
means has overcome all of our problems
but is on just a different trajectory of
growing and stands up taller and
believes in itself there's so much
meaning in that Ryan and I we we are the
minimalist we've been the minimalist for
about a decade now people know us most
from a Netflix documentary that we did
and we talked about minimalism it often
starts with the sort of stuff and we're
talking about America's in the Western
world's obsession with overconsumption
the average American household has
300,000 items in it that'd be fine if
those things we're gonna make us happy
but I think what we've we've often
learned is like we're consuming to sort
of pacify ourselves to to fill a void
that can never be filled with stuff and
when we talk about minimalism we're
often talking about removing the excess
stuff in our lives so we can actually
focus on what's important making room
for what's truly important we're not
monks we're not ascetics we're not
trying to tell people and proselytize
you need to get rid of all of your stuff
what we're trying to do is help people
realize that many of the things we
thought we needed we
probably don't need them as much as we
think and there are some things that can
augment our experience of life and
enhance our experience of life but we
talk about minimalism that's what we're
talking about talk about getting the
sort of excess out of the way and some
people often ask us like it could there
ever be a minimalist president and I I
don't know the answer to that I think
the closest we've ever had is is someone
like Calvin Coolidge and I have some
quotes from him that really stand out to
me and I thought maybe we could talk
about about a few of these because all
today they reminded me of things like if
you were to say well people who to judge
said this I'm doing it's not I'm not
surprised by this on contribution
Coolidge said no person has ever honored
has ever honored for what he has ever
been honored for what he received honor
has been the reward for what he gave and
I think that I think that when you talk
about contribution and and I mean I
think we could talk about honor as well
but what do you think what do you think
about a quote like that I think it makes
a lot of sense and it shows you how
fulfillment doesn't come from how much
we accumulate right but from rather kind
of what we put into the world what we
put out there
I'm the idea of honor is itself an
interesting and sometimes mischievous
concept right because we may go after it
in ways that put too much stock in in
what others think of us but I think
there is something meaningful about the
fact that those we look up to most are
not the ones who have accumulated the
most are surrounded themselves with the
most but rather have put forward the
most or offered a lot and I think that's
not a bad vision to take into the
presidency right it's not about it's not
the kind of office you should seek
because you think you'd like to have it
it's it's a way to get things done and
it's a way to get things done to help
and serve others who place that office
in your hands trusting that you'll do
something good with it and I remember
feeling that with even the position of
mayor not just the policy
responsibilities and
hours that came with it but little
things the fact that just showing up at
somebody's event or giving a plaque to a
kid it did well in school or something
you're basically taking this this thing
that's been placed in your hands and
then using it to make other people feel
good or important and and that's that's
big the symbolic stuff but I talked
about this in the book as well I hated
the symbolic kind of parts of the
mayor's job when I first came in I
thought it was I wasn't invited at first
to it cuz I think I was very similar to
you where it was like I'd rather be
focused on policy and we've got to fill
the potholes right but there there's a
whole other half that is equally
important to the citizens of your city
that's right and I gradually discovered
that the things that are not the
documented functions of the job
consoling somebody who is grieving
congratulating somebody who achieves
something showing up an event when you
have no substantive role just in order
to let the organizers of the event know
that whatever it is they're working on
is important to you and therefore
important to the city that's actually
real that that's a real contribution and
with the presidency too I think that
some of the most important parts of the
presidency are not documented
they're the parts that have to do with
calling people they're their highest
values setting a tone what you do and
what you don't do and you know the
spirit of minimalism the the thing I
often think about with with Coolidge now
that you mention him because honestly I
don't think about Coolidge that much
like this idea of but this idea economy
of words even matters right it's
something I strive for it to try to make
sure that every word that I utter that
there's a pretty good ratio of meaning
to error taken up yeah I feel like I
feel like you speak in prose which is as
refreshing
considering other people on spending
Coolidge says there is no dignity quite
so impressive and no independence quite
so important as living within your means
Ryan I know we were going to talk about
the country sort of living within their
means we have a question about our
podcast is usually very audience driven
so we've got some questions coming in
here but let's talk a moment about
personally like living within our means
you you famously talk about how you have
student debt
and I think that's that's one thing that
is is plugging our country after Student
DEP a consumer debt in general part of
that a big part of that has to do with
us living beyond our means and can you
talk a little bit about that in terms of
personal responsibility and then maybe
we can expand it to the the country as
well living beyond its means yes I think
the important thing is to look at what
debt is supposed to do for us right
there's actually an entire there's a
history I can't remember the name of the
author but a brilliant books been
written it just goes all the way back to
the invention of debt I think if I
remember the book right he suggests that
the concept of debt was invented before
the concept of money and and then we was
Jeffrey Louie maybe or Graber could that
be right anyway somebody can look it up
as we speak and it's very important it's
important part of how we finance public
projects how we smooth in our lives
right if you're trying to be able to
make an investment in your education
you're supposed to be able to borrow
against the earnings that you're gonna
earn in the future because you've got
the education plow those into your own
growth and by it everybody comes out
better the problems emerged when
expectations are misaligned or we take
on more than we can handle or in some
cases and this something worries me a
lot from a policy perspective you know
some of the student debt was run up at
institutions that were exploitative and
never really going to deliver that much
value to their students and
unfortunately the enforcement of that
has been degraded but it's one of the
things I hope to restore as a country I
think this is important from a
generational perspective so it's been
less fashionable in my party Democratic
Party to talk about debt and deficit
largely because I think we resist those
who use it as an excuse not to make
investments but there's a real problem
here I mean there are some fiscal time
bombs that are gonna go off in my
lifetime
and we need to look at what it means to
tell people that we can just continue
cutting taxes and you'll pay less and
less but we'll continue maintaining
these expectations of services and
sooner or later one or the other has to
give either our public life will be
degraded and we'll just make do with
having in fear
roads and diminished health and an
inferior kind of national achievement
sounds like the American dream yeah yeah
or we'll have giant deficits right now
we got both both of those things have
happened yeah but we can set the right
balance between what we contribute into
public things and what we expect from
them and it's part of what my presidency
will seek to do to just have a level of
balance there that is tough it's not
always rewarded politically but it's
needed from the standpoint of prudence
in order to set up the country for
success yeah
when Josh and I when we talk about
consumer debt or personal debt or we
have a philosophy it's if you've heard
of Dave Ramsey but his philosophy is
there's no such thing as good debt and I
think that with my personal side just
became debt-free for the first time of
my life back in 2016 and for me like
that is I haven't felt freer than that
it's like if you know everything hit the
fan I could move apartments cuz you know
I won't be able to afford la rent but I
wouldn't have any debt collectors
chasing me out you know could pretty
much turn my life around on a dime so
consumer that makes sense to me but as a
nation to say there's no such thing as
good debt that doesn't sound right to me
but I know twenty-two trillion dollars
also doesn't sound right to me so I
guess is there a balance where where we
do need to take home some debt and like
where is that balance dude yes so the
the the simplest way to put it is there
are there are things that pay for
themselves and there are things that
don't and we really need to pay
attention to the difference so for
example there was a theory that was
popular for a while that certain kinds
of tax cuts would pay for themselves we
tried it and turns out that's not true
but it's also very clear that certain
investments and things like
pre-kindergarten education or criminal
justice reform or infrastructure do pay
for themselves in that case it would be
irresponsible not to right yeah I mean
it's the simple and people may find it's
better not to bother but also in
personal finance right if you 5 a
mortgage at 3% and I can save at 5% and
get interest on that then I am
sacrificing money by not maintaining a
certain level of debt because if I paid
off the mortgage I'd have that much less
money to say this
you know this is this is a personal
calculation people can make for
themselves but you have to weigh other
call said there's psychological costs
that are having that dead and in other
costs that are sort of non-monetary I
mean it's the same cost like when we
think about bringing a new item into our
lives like of course there's the price
tag right but the true cost goes way
beyond the price tag it's the price of
storing the thing and cleaning the thing
and changing the batteries and the thing
or putting oil and the thing like there
are all of these additional costs and
and I think you're right it's very much
a personal calculus but when we look at
the the country writ large we have we
have a tremendous amount of spending we
have a tremendous amount of debt and in
fact I think we have a question from
from Tim do you want to play that
question podcast Jean living below your
means is a core doctrine of minimalism
as president what steps would you take
to decrease the current national debt of
more than 22 trillion dollars so mayor
Pete I think that you know Tim's asking
for something like is some specificity
here like what what do we do to decrease
is there an appropriate amount of debt
it sounds to me like it's probably not
22 trillion dollars right somewhere
between 0 and 22 trillion I'm assuming
yeah I mean it's a share of our economy
it should be lower than it is but again
it would also be foolish to have 0
because you're then denying yourself
opportunities at a national level right
that can only be financed with the right
level of debt so how do we get it right
well it's pretty simple I mean basically
we need to only take on things that we
can afford then we need to be willing to
raise the revenue to do it I would think
of it this way most developed countries
about a third of their economy flows
through the public in some way if you
add up state local got everything from
you know what goes into schools and
libraries to nationally collected taxes
that you might spend on the military or
national effort it's about a third for
us it's a quarter mmm and in that
difference between a quarter and a third
lies in my view the inferiority of our
public infrastructure our transportation
resources our health and a lot of other
things relative to most of those
developed countries now the real problem
is that we've maintained expectations of
having a high level of infrastructure
and health and in housing but we've cut
the amount we're paying into it down so
it's got to come out of somewhere and
right now where it's coming out of is
that the debt is growing I would argue
that spending is actually it's not
because of spending it's because the
relationship between spending and what
we're bringing in but it is also
abundantly clear that there is more than
enough in this in the abundance of this
country to finance all the expectations
we do have maybe not if we go all the
way it's one of the reasons compared to
my some of my competitors I'm not
promising you know free everything that
that we can just pay down the last penny
of tuition even if you're the wealthiest
person to go to college but I do think
we need to do more than we are now I
mean we should have better travel and
I'm not even asking for Japanese level
trains I just like maybe Italian level
that'd be nice compared to what we got
never and that would if history is any
guide to unlock a lot of economic
potential yeah but you also have to be
willing to pay for it so you know do we
want to continue to live in a world
where you know a company like Amazon can
make billions of dollars in profits and
pay exactly zero in federal taxes in
which case we'll continue to be unable
to pay for our national priorities or we
can do something about that do we want
to continue to live in a world where the
wealthiest among us proportionally
generally pay less in taxes than the
people mopping their floors or we can
adjust that it's a policy question and
in some ways it's also a question of
power because the the wealthiest people
usually are more likely to be the in the
ears of politicians than the people who
mop floors there's not an accident that
these things come about but we sometimes
we talk about like it's just impossibly
out of reach to deliver a decent
standard of living and good public
things good schools good good roads and
so forth and the truth is it's just a
matter of what we're willing to pay for
you bring up college and when I think
about college debt I mean it can be it
can be so crippling I mean I know it's
it's crazy to me that at 18 years old
you can start to take on six figures
worth of debt but you can't go and buy a
beer and and I am NOT one for regulation
like I think you know we do need it
sometimes but when I look at college is
charging so much
it's almost like there has to be there's
got to be some give somewhere where I
guess what I'm asking is is like do you
think that that would be like a wise
move like to regulate like what colleges
could charge and couldn't charge versus
you know what their students are earning
after they graduate is there an answer I
guess to the to the college debt
situation where you could come at it is
and we have a set of initiatives I
wouldn't undertake on reducing college
cost and giving you a way to to reduce
your debt afterwards but but from a kind
of philosophical level part of what we
could do is just examine the ratio of
how much of the cost is being placed
onto the student versus an investment
for example states that invest in good
public colleges tend to come out ahead
and that's a collective investment paid
for even by people who won't go to
college but they're paying something
into having a robust state university
system because that'll boost the economy
but the idea of paying for it completely
means you're asking people who won't go
to college who as a general rule make
less right to pay for everybody who does
who is a general rule will make more I
do think that's philosophically
problematic I and that's one of the
reasons I'm a little allergic to the
idea that we're just gonna kind of blow
away all cost right but you're right
there's also question about okay how
much are we keeping on here and and how
much of this I mean the minimalism
framework might be an interesting one
here if you think about the the
accoutrements of a university right how
much of it is part of what is needed in
order to have a university function well
to grow knowledge and inquiry and create
the spaces in which ideas even even
risky ideas can be kicked around and
tested and people can commit themselves
full-time to learning as much as you
possibly can about yourself in the world
around them and how much is it just
stuff yeah it seems that that tuition
costs have have gone up in proportion to
the bloating of sort of the
administrative complex within yeah it's
almost the function of bureaucracy is to
create more bureaucracy in a way I had
this uh.this New Yorker cartoon right
here and it's a guy at the doctor's
office and he said has your ad on the
other side of the counter says
your address insurance or family
relationship change since you started
filling out these forms and and I feel
that way with with any of these large
bureaucratic institutions where there is
there's a need for some bureaucracy
there's a need for some some
organization but as it continues to
expand doesn't mean we're getting more
professors we're getting more ideas in
there we're getting more layers of
administration and when the costs go up
Ryan was talking about a moment ago the
they sort of the problem is that it
almost becomes predatory lending at some
point the 18 year old who does get into
six figures worth of debt it's two steps
removed from the corner store alone that
charged you thirty four hundred percent
interest well and one thing that's going
on that doesn't get as much attention is
for every you know middle or upper
middle class student who's got a
six-figure debt and it's it's a real
wait but they will eventually get
through it
there is a low income student who has
maybe five figure debt that is going to
prevent them from ever being able to get
out because they're so low income on the
way and and you know some of these
colleges especially these for-profit
colleges that that can really take
advantage of people if there's no
quality control I have as you said I
mean they basically turned the
Department of Education into a predatory
lender and their needs I did my view
there needs to be a much higher level of
accountability around that the question
of bureaucracy it'll always be with us
you know when I was in the military I
basically participated in the largest
and most bureaucratic bureaucracy in
America which is the Department of
Defense and there are some things that
it does incredibly well any better than
anybody in the world and then there's
sometimes you're in what one officer I
knew called a self licking ice cream
cone where it just nobody knows why
they're doing what they're doing but
everybody's doing it a lot in triplicate
and it just takes on a life of its own
and as mayor I've always tried to
declutter our own smaller bureaucracy
that I oversee in the city government to
make sure that any process that exists
exists for a reason and that if there's
any place where we're doing something in
step 7 steps and it could be for that we
root that out and find it
and make sure that we're coming back to
our actual mission speaking of being the
governor of a city in the industrial
Midwest yeah we're worth three 37
year-old guys well I just 1038 from the
industrial Midwest and right what do you
think what do you think the rest of the
country can learn from the industrial
Midwest from from I don't know what
maybe where where does a badge of honor
now but I always thought of it as
pejorative when people call it the Rust
Belt yeah I know you're mayor in Dayton
hates the term I think we might lean
into it a little bit let's just own it
yeah there's beauty in the rust
yeah so the funny thing now I think
especially since 2016 is the the Rust
Belt at least politically became
fashionable right people were ignoring
us for a long time and now they're like
studying us with exotic fascination
reporters rock up there like take me to
your dive bar I wanna I want to
understand that you know the political
soul of the the Rust Belt and I think
really that the big thing is to learn
about change and to examine how we can
cope with change in ways that make us
better off I mean by one reckoning the
some of the best things that ever
happened were the technological
developments in the last 50 years
and yet the impact on communities like
where you and I grew up has been
devastating and so then it forces us to
ask okay how do we face these changes
make sure that they actually work in a
way that benefits all of us or more of
us instead of entire communities moving
in the opposite direction of the rest of
the country economically and and yet the
other thing you see in a lot of these
communities is tremendous amount of
creativity because it took so much more
innovation and ingenuity and grit just
to literally stay open maybe in a place
where the economy was collapsing around
you then it takes to make a buck in the
middle of a gold rush or somewhere that
you also see this this level of I mean
what people have cobbled together in
areas where they don't have a lot to
work with is amazing and also this what
I'm very proud to see is this kind of
militant identity emerging in the Rust
Belt that we take some pride in it we
own it and again I think it's because
it's just plain more interesting to
participate in the resurrection of a
place that was left for
than it is to be part of a place that's
that's just kind of humming along and
doesn't have a lot of problems yeah yeah
one thing we're trying to do right now
is were the west side of Dayton about
40% of the population lives there but
it's one of the largest food deserts in
the country there's not a single grocery
store on the west side and so we've
partnered up with a place called Jim
City Market and we've encouraged our
audience that people who have never even
been to Dayton Ohio and they know about
they know how because the minimalists
talked about it every other podcast but
to try to to shine a light on it and
we've had we've had people who visit
yeah they'll go send us tweets all the
time what you know what dive-bar do I go
to as I'm driving through you know my
way to Indianapolis or wherever and I
think that sense of place it the the
sort of there's almost a creative
constraint there that because it is not
a boomtown and you have you know just a
few scraps to work with there there's a
sense of pride but also there's a
creativity that emerges from that that I
think doesn't emerge if you don't have
that sort of that pressure to create the
Diamonds history and Southbend I'm sure
you've seen that as well a lot has
changed a lot of the the factories are
no longer factories now they're they're
sort of tech startups and and they've
changed appreciably from the 1962
what was it Studebaker that's right yeah
the this sort of collapsed there can we
talk a little bit about that yeah we
were a company town for Studebaker and I
grew up not even realizing it was
unusual to have collapsing factories and
empty houses around because that was
just the story of our city we lost
thirty thousand people when they closed
in the sixties is only after I left and
came back and I realized how stark that
was but you know my campaign
announcement happened in a an 800
thousand square foot Studebaker Factory
that I think is only still there because
it was too big to blow up and nobody was
quite sure what to do with it and now
we're in a partnership to make it into
largely take advantage of the fact that
there's a lot of fiber optic cable
running along the same rail way right
away so that served the factories
that can now be used to help us with the
data center economy so you know there's
ups and downs and it's tricky to make it
all work but there's growth now
happening on the very a courage where we
were making cars creating jobs in these
industries didn't exist when we weren't
making cars and it's another example of
how in a way we're doing what we always
did which is taking what's around us
fashioning value out of it and doing
something innovative and new because you
could argue that the auto industry in
the 20s is very much like the the tech
industry of the early 2000s but also
fashioning that that future in a way
that responds to our tradition and
there's a there's a beauty in it there
there's a joy in it and we're proud of
what we've been able to do precisely
because of how much we were on the ropes
for such a long time and everybody
should on your way to date and swing by
South Bend and enjoy the life of our
city we got some lightning around
questions let's dive into some of those
we do this is where we answered some
questions from social media so this is
from a tiny how difficult would it be to
get rid of the electoral college if we
want to be a true democracy and not a
republic shouldn't the popular vote be
what gets counted totally agree every
other election we run in this country
you give it to the person who got the
most votes
yeah and generally when a democracy is
picking its president I think it's
appropriate to give it to the person who
got the most votes how difficult would
it be very difficult but I think we
should do it now there's an interstate
compact that's going around where states
more and more states are pledging that
they would if enough states sign on then
they will give their electoral college
votes to whoever wins the popular vote
so that's a way to do it without having
to change the constitution I actually
believe it changed like this deserves a
constitutional amendment and it might
take 10 or 20 years to get it done all
the more reason I believe to start
talking about it now yeah because right
now what's happening is it's not even
helping systematically helping small
states it's just helping certain states
so your vote in California my vote in
Indiana don't matter because California
is too collectively too liberal and
Indiana's collectively too conservative
but it also drowns out the votes of
liberals in Indiana and conservatives in
California there's a fear that rural
areas might be disadvantaged but the
reality is you know when you're running
for governor which is a race that we run
in the true
why you know person who gets the most
votes wins people still go to rural
areas because you're trying to speak to
all the different kinds of voters that
you serve I think the same is true
nationally and so we would just be a
little a little more worthy of the name
of democracy if we got it done now to
play devil's advocate there wouldn't you
have I mean wouldn't someone argue that
we're not in a democracy though we are
part of a republic and yeah to me that's
that's kind of an academic distinction I
mean of course we're not a direct
democracy where you vote on your iPhone
on every bond issue that the government
does but democracy to me is a value and
what matters is how democratic is our
democratic republic and i would argue
it's not Democratic enough there may be
such a thing as too much democracy I
think California sometimes does its best
to explore just how far you can go in
the direction of democracy but when it
comes to decisions like how we pick our
president or whether our Congress is set
up according to districts that even
remotely reflect kind of balanced a
version of the American people very
mandarin maps
brutal it's unbelievable it's brutal and
I don't think there's any principled
defense of how that works so I guess
what I'm saying is let's make our
democratic republic more democratic yeah
totally agree all right the next
question we got is from Vanessa how
important is the idea of freedom to you
and how would you incorporate this into
how you lead the country so the idea of
freedom is central to my campaign will
be central to my presidency the thing
I'm doing this a little different is
that part of my my campaign is about
recognizing the government is not the
only thing that can make you on free
mhmmm and so we're trying to look at
freedom as the freedom to live a life of
your choosing sometimes that means
government getting out of the way I
believe that's the case on something
like the woman's right to choose or the
right of somebody like me to choose my
own spouse without being told by a
county clerk based on her idea of her
religion who I ought to marry part of it
though requires the government to step
up to make sure that we have a system
for health care where everybody can get
health care because then I'm more free
to go start a small business or a
podcast or whatever because I know I'll
have coverage part of it is the the
freedom that that can only come to us if
we have good education which means we
have to invest in education so
delivering freedom is not as easy as
eliminating
the state otherwise the freest country
in the world would probably be Somalia
but it does mean that we have to
transcend this argument over how big or
how small the government is going to be
and ask at every turn is this measure
going to make us more free or less free
if we also have to identify what is
freedom less sometimes we think about
freedom as doing whatever you want
whenever you want but my six-year-old
daughter if I let her do whatever she
wants whenever she wants that she would
go out and play in the street you know
it's tyranny in a way if you're doing
whatever you want whenever you want I
think real real freedom also involves a
sort certain amount of self-restraint
and and and discipline otherwise we're
just bouncing around like a pinball
that's right you can think of it as for
example an alarm clock an alarm clock is
a contract between your higher-order
self and your lizard brain because your
lizard brain just wants to sleep because
you're tired but your higher-order self
has decided that you have an appointment
at a certain time in the morning and you
need to make it and so you set the alarm
clock it's like an agreement between
your night self and your morning self
and government can be like that too
there's a law school whose motto
includes talking about the those wise
constraints that make us free and we
always have to think about freedom in a
richer sense because there's a lot more
to it than just running around doing
whatever we feel like do you talk about
the role of faith in in your life
because I know we often hear politicians
talk about it but it tends to be
politicians on the other side of the
aisle we have a lot of people of faith
in in our audience we also have a lot of
atheists and I was like talk to you
about how it's played a role in your
life this is very important to me
personally officially but first of all I
believe that when you're in office you
have an obligation to treat people of
any religion and people of no religion
equally and that's a very important
American principle that is not always I
think being honored right now
but I also think it's fair game for
those of us who are guided by faith to
talk about it and to explain how it
shapes our worldview and right now I'm
also trying to remind people of faith
that they have a choice because you
would almost forget by the way that some
self-styled religious political
officials talk you'd almost forget about
how much at least in the
Christian tradition that I'm part of is
about looking after the marginalized and
identifying with the prisoner and
welcoming the stranger and feeding the
hungry that this is the very stuff of
salvation at least on on one reading of
of Christian faith and yet you would
think all there was to it was a certain
certain view of the world that's being
enforced by by some self-described
religious leaders now so you know
scripture like the Constitution admits
of many interpretations and people argue
that's part of what it is something
people argue over how to make sense of
it but for me a lot of it has to do with
recognizing what is bigger than you
recognizing what is bigger than your
powers of understanding will ever touch
that's why in the Pisco paling our
liturgy we talk about the peace that
passes all understanding literally means
there's things that go past
understanding right and having a certain
amount of humility about that if there's
the biggest thing I get from faith is
humility
which can also be very freeing in a
sense because it means you don't have to
be or resolve everything you talk about
one of your biggest failures well I've
had some election results that were
pretty brutal you win some you lose some
there's a chapter in my book about the
experience of running for state
treasurer an office nobody had heard of
and nobody had heard of me either and I
was running as a Democrat in Indiana in
2010 which is one of the worst years
ever for Democrats and I absolutely got
my head handed to me and yet I think I
learned more in that campaign than any
campaign up until this one where I'm
running for president and you know
turned out the outcome of the campaign
was less important in my own development
at least then the experience of engaging
with people who some of whom were never
going to agree with me and still trying
to reach some level of understanding and
it served me well when I turned around
and did go on to run for mayor and I
think it served me well now what do you
learn from this campaign hmm well
there's not a lot of time for reflection
so I think I'll be better able to answer
that question when it's all run its
course but I guess the biggest thing
I've learned is that
people are intimately affected by what
happens in politics right now it's being
talked about like it's just this show
like just who called who what name and
what was the tweet today and all this
fighting on cable and through it all
people are finding their lie everything
from the level of bullying going on in
schools to whether you can get a job
with benefits is all tied up in in our
politics and all our politics is
personal for somebody and you know I've
always believed that kind of
philosophically but when you're on the
trail and people coming up to you at
these rope lines saying here's what's
going on in my life
and here's what I'm hoping you will do
as president or what I wish you talked
more about or what I want candidates to
speak to you see just how how central
this is even if people don't maybe
realize that politics is shaping their
lives I think it's my job to learn about
that and then and then explain it and
play it out for folks here's how your
life is different because there's this
president instead of that President or
this law instead of that law and then
make the case for why it would be better
when we do it our way yeah it sounds a
really mature no I really appreciate
following you in the media how I mean I
haven't seen it if you have where like I
don't hear you bashing any of your
opponents on either side and I think
that's really commendable I try not to
be let's talk a little bit about
nostalgia because Ryan and I have
written about this in the past and
nostalgia is sort of this rose-colored
rearview mirror it's almost a
two-dimensional view of a past that
didn't really exist regardless of what
you think of Donald Trump I the the I
actually like 3/4 of his his slogan of
make America great again it's that again
part that actually and if it were your
slogan I would be telling you the same
thing I may repeat that the again thing
acknowledges something that actually
didn't exist so make America great
sounds great to me going back to this
past where more people were oppressed
and things weren't actually as beautiful
as as maybe we thought they were is that
is that a fair assessment of nostalgia
yeah you know Toni jut the historian
wrote a book about ten years ago that
anticipates a lot about the moment we're
in right now but he tries to situate it
in modern kind of post-war history and
then he has this line and there's
something like he says you know the past
is neither better nor nor worse than now
it is just different and the past really
is another country there's no going
there and I think well we have to the I
agree I think there's no honest politics
that can revolve around the word again
and we're not going to find our
greatness by retrieving it pickled out
of some other moment there are things
that we have probably lost in the past
that we might want to recover and that's
what the that's the healthiest part of
the conservative instinct but there's
also a lot in the past that we do not
want to go back yeah and so we need to
view the past as a as a book to be
learned from not a place we want to go
and if we learn from it the right way
then then we find the things that were
most noble or choice worthy about our
past
individually or collectively and then
talk about how to how to kind of recover
that in a new fashion that takes us to
places we couldn't go otherwise
nostalgia look I I'm nostalgic about
times that I know I was miserable at the
time but I feel nostalgic about him now
it's just the way our our mind relates
to the I mean way it's a good thing it
helps us put in perspective things we
didn't appreciate it at the time but it
also is it is very risky and and it's
why I think more than anything we just
got to think in terms of of good and
harm who was being harmed by the way
things worked in the past in the book
I've got a little meditation toward the
end about what it would be like to walk
one of them my predecessors as mayor
through the streets of South Bend today
and I'm sure in some ways they'd be
horrified to see the collapse of all
these factories these industries that
they knew as a great places these they
saw and that's the same time you know
they lived in a world where you died a
lot younger and if you were any kind of
minority it just sucked by today's
standards and we kind of wash that away
and are in our nostalgia for how things
were we are living in one of those
moment
that I think people will be fascinated
with and if we get it right maybe
nostalgic about one day not right now I
mean right now it's pretty bleak but I
mean the choices we're about to make are
the stuff of history we are lucky and
unlucky enough to be living in this
moment that I think is gonna shape at
least the next 50 years yeah and what
comes next could be really ugly or it
could be really enlightened and my hope
is that we wind up choosing to do the
kinds of things that people will one day
wanna read about and write about and
dream about as they're deciding how to
get things even further alright we've
got a bunch more to talk about including
we're gonna have mayor Pete read some
onion headlines about mayor Pete we've
got a bunch more questions as well a lot
more discussion coming up and if you
want to hear all that you can listen to
this week's maximal episode available
exclusively on patreon that's right
you're currently listening to our weekly
minimal episode but every week Ryan and
I record an entirely different much
longer it's always over an hour long
form maximal episode over on the
minimalists private podcast which gives
us the private space we need to talk
about things we don't typically talk
about in public Plus patreon is the best
way for us to fund this podcast and keep
it 100% advertisement free because
advertisements suck when you subscribe
to the minimalist private podcast on
patreon you'll also receive a personal
link so that our maximal episodes play
right there on your favorite podcast app
you'll also get a link to our entire
back catalog of more than a hundred
private podcast episodes and it's
probably getting closer to 200 private
podcast episodes now around easy time
flies yes indeed so you can find all the
details and all the good stuff including
an additional private podcast episode
every week over at the minimalists com
slash support Ryan what else you got for
us this week being informed is more
important than ever especially in these
times with the primaries coming up and
then the presidential election coming up
I mean don't just trust the headlines I
mean it's okay to read a headline but
especially there onion headline right
definitely don't trust the onion
headlines but it's okay to read
headlines but read read the rest of the
article just do some research before
making you know these bold statements
about these different candidates because
you really don't know unless you dig
into it you know I'd like to say
something real quick Ryan I think it's
probably I tried to touch on this at the
beginning but you and I have we have
different political beliefs and
times they align that they overlap of a
intersect we like freedom and we didn't
have mayor Pete on today to to try to
endorse him in any way what we want to
try to do is expose the world to someone
like him who does have some good ideas
and also has some ideas that we both
disagree with it's okay to have a
conversation with someone whom you
disagree with on some topics well dude I
mean is as divided and I'm not trying to
get all preachy here man but as divided
as the country is right now
it's like we need to have conversations
like that with all sides yeah if we
can't have conversations like that then
we just become further divided and that
is that's not good for anymore living in
the United States of America and we
would definitely extend this invitation
to other people at any other top-tier
candidate similar to peace so yeah if
Bernie wants to come on if Elizabeth
Warren wants to come on dude if Trump
wanted to come on I'd be more than happy
to have a conversation I would sit down
and have a conversation with Donald
Trump for sure and and I think we need
to be willing to have these
conversations with people that we agree
with and we disagree with it because
here's what you'll find out you can't
disagree with someone about everything
even we had a carnivore and a vegan on
the podcast we ended up talking about
mostly the things they agree on even
though their diets were completely
different if your political diet is
completely different from mine I can
still find some common ground and we can
agree yeah hey Josh do you want to hear
some voicemail comments and tips from
our listeners let's do it all right here
you go hey Ryan hey Josh this is Lisa
from Minnesota
my advice to your listeners who are
moving and are wondering what to take
and what to leave behind is imagine you
are in your new home and you open a box
and you there is the thing that you are
wondering about whether you want to take
and are you thinking wow I'm so glad to
see this I cannot wait to use this in my
new home or are you thinking oh man what
the heck was I thinking why did I tack
this what the heck am I going to do with
this so hopefully this will make things
more clarity of listeners thanks
hi my name is jamie middleton and i live
in orlando florida I did have some ideas
about things with kids I recently in
within the last couple of years on my
birthday isn't a Christmas I said you
know I don't want things I'd rather just
do things with you guys I'd rather have
experiences so we take a trip or we go
someplace really fun or special also
instead of buying things for your kids
we like have a membership to a Science
Museum a Children's Museum and those are
great things to ask for if people are
looking for gifts for you as a family or
for your kids get a Zoo membership or
ask for a museum membership because you
can make that last all through the year
and those are places that your children
can go and play with quote-unquote toys
that are free that won't do someone else
and they have to manage the clutter and
you don't alright Joe thanks again to
Mayor Pete for joining us today if you
want to check out his book I'll hold it
up for the YouTube audience here it's
called shortest way home it really is a
beautifully written book and it
surprised me because I expected to get a
couple chapters in just so I could learn
a little bit about this guy who was the
mayor of South Bend Indiana but I ended
up I was on vacation earlier this year
read the whole thing and was it was
engrossing and I've could never say that
about another political minute him
online Pete for america.com and real
quick for writing right here right now
here's one thing that's going on in the
life of the minimalists I teach a
writing class speaking of beautiful
writing if you want your writing to be
as beautiful as Pete's it's how to write
better org I've been teaching this
writing class for about six years now
it's an online writing class I've had
students who are medical doctors
students who are high school students
and sort of everything in between the
commonality is people want to improve
their writing whether it's business
emails or you want to write your first
book or you want to start a blog you
want to learn how to write better tweets
the rising tide lifts all boats and if
you want to learn how to write better
and go to how to write better dot or
that's when my tweets are so awesome
question comment or minimalism tip for a
podcast leave a voicemail for zero six
two one nine seven
3:9 or send a voice memo to podcast at
the minimalists comm you can comment on
this episode at youtube.com slash to the
minimalists if you want our show notes
in your inbox sign up for our emails
over at the minimalists comm you also
receive our simple Sunday emails for our
added value this week I wanted to go way
back Ryan we're talking about one of the
most taboo subjects on earth politics
yeah but we wanted it to really be the
original meaning of the word politics
you go back to the the the the Greek
root it really just means the affairs of
the city and that's why I thought
starting with Pete and having a
conversation with him because he's
actually managed the affairs of a city
yeah that's what politics means yeah and
so I think we got we got into that
conversation a bit today but it is a
taboo subject so here is one of the
greatest songs from one of the greatest
voices of any generation hears sweetest
taboo from Shaw Day and if you leave
here today with just one message we hope
it's this love people and use things
because the opposite never works thanks
for listening y'all we'll see you next
time and minimus